hey how's it going bros my name is Pete
so today we're playing superhot beta
this game came out with a prototype and
people lost their [ __ ] because they
thought it was the coolest thing ever
and the Kickstarter for it was very
successful and now they wants to back
the Kickstarter sorry I support video
games got to play the beta and this this
is us playing the beta hey I've got a
new game it's like a shooter but you see
action from your eyes trippy stuff oh my
god what the [ __ ] that I just took ok
it's very Matrixyl there you go I just
blasted that [ __ ] out of the [ __ ]
smithereens move with ok so the point of
this game for those of you don't know
yet is that time moves when I move a bit
about you see that a bat a bat just
shoot shoot him in the face and then I'm
gonna move a little bit to the side and
I'm gonna shoot that son of a [ __ ] in
the face I got shot in the titty
I don't think I know how to play the
baby just give me one brief little
centimeter of a second that's apparently
a thing and kill the ball got it no
[ __ ] way how did I miss embarrassing
I'm gonna shoot you yes what happened Oh
super Oh grab the gun got it
this is they really ate okay I'll grab
this please and then I will shoot
and I will shoot you in the day you're
the deck man trying to shoot him it was
a setup
god damn it oh god no it's a trap
oh they're everywhere ah you'll hit me
oh you can't hit this come on oh gosh
haha you think just cuz you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't know what I'm saying
okay we got this oh yes I'm sure ah
thank you game so weird so weird
you missed throw your gun did it I did
it barrels yeah that's right I did it I
don't remember the beta being this hard
man I [ __ ] suck where are they
how do you want me ah and then I pick up
this that's pretty badass
how about no stun the enemy I stunned
you and I pick up this and I shoot you
and then I'm gonna shoot you in
that's right Oh God and YouTube and
YouTube
why are you crystal people anyway [ __ ]
off Chris so people that's right Chris
the people oh god I'm out of ammo
I threw the gun and then I'm gonna grab
this one and then I'm gonna shoot yes
damn it
throw the gun punch no why did I throw
it again
no okay look at this BAM
good good [ __ ]
the bifida that baby bear why can't we
just I'll take that stuff whoa sucking
on my titties like you wanted me calling
me how could I miss thank you thank you
everyone all right
um miss awkward what do we do now okay
ah stress what do you want from me
hi oh okay Raab little Oh got it got it
Oh for safety aah what just happened
yes get over it what I'll just go this
out all right
I'll listen to the game from that word
fabulous oh man it's getting pretty
badass but thank you sir now who's next
[ __ ]
okay now it's [ __ ] cool it rises so
much of the matrix we like the agents
spawning in and [ __ ] what does it say
I'll be grabbing this sir nowadays SAP
oh that's right I'm super hot oh so hot
you can't even touch me look at this
jewel a better bat bat bat this is what
happened in real time that's pretty
badass I didn't realize that was the
case cool it's a cool concept it's it's
almost weird that no one's done it
before and I'll have my drink
Oh God go bottle I hit him in the face
with now anyone want to [ __ ] with me oh
my god it's so cool oh god he dodged no
he didn't finish this is mine now [ __ ]
that's right [ __ ]
I'm from the streets ow unfinished
business
gotta tap that ass that's right tap that
ass oh god I tap that ass too hard
goddamn it that's the second time this
week
dance talk alright bit a bit better give
it a bit a Bell bell give it a bat bat
bat bat bat man babble about the Bell
no I want to dance more it okay thank
you oh thank you
what song Britney please be Britney ah
of course that's disconnected
cool enough for today
while the game said it bros the game
said it itself really cool game I think
you're both so check it out there's a
lot of great games coming out recently a
lot of great indie games which I really
love
I had a lot of fun playing this if you
bros had fun it feel free to leave a
like hit subscriber Cumbre today I'll
see you bros as always in the next video
and as always stay awesome press oh my
god he sings
this is the greatest game of all time
but in sweetest music in this game
oh my [ __ ] god